does it make you feel sad that the love
that you're looking for
is the love that you had
taylor swift stuns and stirs up some
trouble in a new music video for i bet
you think about me off her recorded
album now called red taylor's version it
was an amazing experience taylor's
co-star actor miles teller who plays a
groom haunted by visions of his ex on
his wedding day teller's real-life wife
kelly also stars as the other bride
meanwhile taylor is there to crash the
event grabbing a handful of wedding cake
and even teaching the kids table how to
flip the bird
[Music]
fittingly red remains an ever-present
theme throughout the video as swift's
wedding dress eventually fades to
crimson swifties might also notice a nod
to an infamous piece of neckwear first
referenced in taylor's hit all too well
i found i
left my scarf there at your sister's
house and you've still got it
in your drawer even though
the scarf pops up again in the video
when taylor gifts it to the bride many
fans speculate the scarf is a reference
to actor jake gyllenhaal who taylor
reportedly dated back in 2010.
speaking of famous faces taylor tapped
one to direct the video oh yeah yep
blake lively makes her directorial debut
like how lucky am i swift gave fans a
look at her bestie hard at work behind
the scenes in this tick tock better than
your favorite [ __ ]
[Music]
blake and hubby ryan reynolds showed up
to support taylor in new york city over
the weekend after her snl appearance
where she performed her 10 minute
version of all too well
[Music]
[Applause]
but blake isn't the only one who has
been busy behind the camera taylor also
wrote and directed her new all too well
short film starring sadie sink and dylan
o'brien
at the premiere swift opened up to et
about the experience
it was as all-consuming as writing a
song is i i really directing i i felt as
fulfilled by it as i did
when i craft a song and think about
every aspect of it and it comes together
and then it goes out in the world there
are so many moving pieces but honestly
the actors sadie and dylan
they just gave everything and i trusted
them so much because i've watched
everything they've done i've been a fan
of theirs for ages and so i knew
i knew
i had i had a feeling if you put these
two people in a room and you trust their
instincts
magical things could happen
[Music]
you